Vice President Mike Pence will meet with
Venezuela x' opposition leader Juan why
doe in Colombia today as been as well as
government cracks down again on protests
violent border clashes killed at least
two people and injured hundreds more
over the weekend why don't the
international community to consider all
options to resolve the crisis the u.s.
is backing him to replace president
Nicolas Maduro Manuel Bojorquez is just
across the border in cucuta Colombia we
are walking near a bridge which connects
Colombia to Venezuela and on the other
side it is being blocked by the Maduro
regime part of the fierce resistance to
a us-backed plan to bring humanitarian
aid into Venezuela now leaders from
across the world are once again calling
for a coordinated effort to get the aid
in tensions erupted into violence as
Venezuelan citizens marching to the
Colombian border to collect humanitarian
aid were met with tear gas and rubber
bullets fired by officers in riot gear
opposition leader Huang Guido arrived in
Colombia's capital yesterday slamming
the attack as an unprecedented crime he
will ask leaders during an emergency
summit today to help bring down the
current regime by any means necessary
but Venezuelan president Nicolas Maduro
continues to deny his country is facing
a crisis refusing to allow aid in and
cutting off diplomatic ties with
neighboring Colombia for cooperating
with what he calls a us-led coup we
can't keep putting up with Colombian
territory being used for attacks against
Venezuela Maduro said patience is
exhausted I can't bear it anymore this
is the worst of the worst of a tyrant
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
challenged Maduro and his forces to back
down and said the United States would
not rule out military force every
options on the table we're gonna do the
things that need to be done to make sure
that democracy rains aside from a
military option vice president Pence is
expected to announce another measure
later today additional sanctions against
Moscow
government for CBS this morning I'm
Manuel Bojorquez in cucuta Colombia